yeah i think everybody has their own
thing i think uh
you know there's artists who say things
in an extremely simple way but the way
they say it is
their character what they stand for you
know the way they say it
you know i think that there's guys who
rap really [ __ ] fast that don't say
anything
they all flow oh that's just the flow
and there are
there are people who could do both
there's people who rap like that that
are [ __ ] fired
you're like um yeah m tech nine like
there's some dudes who could really get
down but like i think that just
everybody has their own thing like
you know and then there's guys like
royce who are like [ __ ] old
nice jedis oh yeah like royce the five
nine can do
anything this pen is elite oh it's crazy
do you like it like intimidating when
you know you're like
did you first of all do you know royce
is getting on the record like or is this
something you send to him i'm gonna be
real with you bro
i ain't intimidated by nobody i work in
a session with lil wayne lil wayne my
god
but i mean royce is a much better rapper
than little win for the record
it's debatable little wayne is bigger
it's debatable
i don't know man race is a [ __ ]
murderer bro i got to be in the studio
with royce to really because i witnessed
this man wheezy like
it's different off the top record the
verse
and say i don't like the middle erase
the middle
and then go back in and just no not go
back in he's still there
and do it right there after he said
eraser yeah so you
you've seen wayne's creative process
what is that like is it no pen
is it no no pen no pen it's just he
might listen to the beat a few times
chuckle laugh a little bit and then walk
to the bottom did he just punch in as he
goes
no one shot deal really and if he don't
like alan or he don't like to go back
and fix it just say yeah let's do that
over do you how do you
do your thing because obviously you're
the one of writers one take
you know what i mean you don't write
down anything no no no no no you do okay
oh yeah right
i'm not trying to force myself to bust
my brain to try to remember that but
yeah i've noticed nowadays like uh
a lot of rappers especially now with the
way like melody infused music has like
kind of taken over
like a lot of artists they'll just go
into the booth and then they'll like
they'll lay down like uh the melody like
and then they'll sit there and listen to
it and then they'll just punch in line
by line that's like
that's like what when somebody needs a
ghost writer
you i you you let me hit a beat and you
tell me like
you're mumbled to it this is the type of
flow flow because now you need the word
i've seen it it's actually it's a
reference it's it's like yo they'll lay
that down and then they'll sit there and
smoke and listen and then they'll go in
and just punch in
no but it's but that's it but it's it's
so creative it's still creative it's
still true
it's just not just i feel like it's
harder to
be able to say what you want to say and
get your point across
without thinking about it too much
because bubby rahman
multiple words meaning multiple
things at the same time with metaphors
punchlines and
it's just it's just you know i'm a fan
of that